hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to what probably is the
final episode of resident evil village
i'm assuming this is where lady
demotrescu pops out of the woods
re-emerges in all of her glorious self
maybe nude
maybe not but her final redemption
arrives
and we discovered that it was actually
lady dimitrescu
who's pulling the strings and was
impersonating as miranda who was
impersonating as mia
this is your last chance okay
little well ominous somehow i didn't get
enough
juicy game i don't even know where that
was gonna be
but i don't need it because i'm tough
and i got lady dim trisco on my side
baby we're gonna make it through this if
you believe in me
then i believe in you and i believe in
us
i believe in everything that we have one
moment please moment please indeed
all right we're ready let's do this
what'd you say to me bullets i got a lot
of shooty gun ammo
37 37
oh yeah okay some shooty bullets one of
these things
okay good to go we actually have a lot
of like the refined metal
but i don't think i'm gonna need to use
it i honestly do not
and i know i could have upgraded the
shotgun to something better but hey
classic is just fine with me okay we're
good to go
we're good to go we good to try this all
right miranda you [ __ ]
give me back my daughter my weird fungus
daughter
my weird mold baby well that's a little
strange
let's do this uh peekaboo anybody want a
bullet
way yeah well what if i just run past
you why am i not running yeah
you don't screw you i don't even need to
shoot you why would i waste the ammo go
out of my way
yeah you're not going to do anything to
me yeah okay
i know it's what i'm trying to do
come to me
is that you oh
how i've missed you
what
[Music]
my power is leaving me
oh no
what is her power anyway miranda
boom bang i'd shoot now interesting
your body certainly isn't normal nor my
dog stop talking about my body
now you will see once i kill you
properly
get her now
thank you thanks for the help
more bangs more shooties
and you try to take it away from me
my desires will be fulfilled
rose is mine
what the [ __ ]
everybody's got a gimmick all right
what's yours
all right ladies
[Music]
and gentlemen my false children and
awakened the glorious
stop dancing god why is everyone on a
dance with me please do not worry for
little rose
i assure you i'll provide her with truth
well i mean if i thought you wanted
eva's
well all this dancing is really nice but
how many times have i said over the last
few episodes
don't dance how can you deny me
why the hell can't you realize rose is
my goddamn kid
not true ow hey listen
i got plenty of goose juice so you're
not gonna go anywhere with this
miss me maybe i don't know
i've never seen a human live without
are you sure um i mean i'm pretty sure
it's clear that uh
i'm one of you maybe i'm even better
than you
gucci please i shall put you to rest
oh
my god
[Music]
yeah it seems to have that effect on
people especially those who deny that
they're insane bruhman
they seem to be even more insane
everyone dies
hello hi oh nice bags
oh they're so gooshy no
are you ow
[Music]
will this kill you a shotgun to the face
hey handgun oh i probably need that for
those
stop stop i don't i don't consent
well i am using up my goose can you just
please
no you no you die no you no you die
no you there we go pop your balloons
no birthday for either
yeah especially you huh
[Music]
yay
i don't know if i'm doing anything am i
doing anything
no it's me
well this is awfully fascinating i don't
know if i'm hitting you right or
i gotta like blast you right between the
eyes okay
what no i don't know what are the dark
gods what do the dark gods have to do
with any
what is that okay
sorry did i pop the wrong balloon
okay oh hi well this is interesting
you messed with my eyeballs you changed
my eyeball settings now mr winters
i think it's time you left in my house
okay the hell i will
listen
if you you know just because you say it
doesn't mean you love it hey
that's my daughter well why'd your
daughter die in the first place was it
the flu did you see the flu
i understand
okay it doesn't seem like you do
if i combine rose with a mega mice my
daughter will be made
manifest at last i've waited a century
a century all for this day
uh-huh well maybe you should have been
nicer to the other kids
after all everyone dies
i think you said that already you know
you keep saying things about me dying
but you seem to be the one
full of bullets so really what is it
oh that's not good
now so close today she's my goddamn
daughter
you psycho
[Music]
oh man i really wish i didn't have to
spend so much popping these goddamn
i don't have yeah
oh come on okay this is getting silly
how many how many how many how many
we shouldn't have wasted all my pistols
[Music]
they could do nothing to assuage my
years of knowledge
oh my god
you're not capable of real love
yeah probably
my goodness just
die already ow
am i doing something i must be doing
something wrong
i must be doing something because
there's no way
that it would
okay and now we're in here again am i do
is there a mechanic that i'm not
sure about
i'm there must be something that i'm
missing because i've been shooting a lot
and uh not a lot is happening i will
take
my daughter miss
swinging a miss okay swinging a miss
okay back to the normal dancing am i
am i stupid here am i stupid am i silly
am i
dumb am i dumb
i shall put you to rest am i
dumb am i dumb am i dumb am i dumb
there's gotta be something else there's
got to be something else that i'm
missing here
there has to be because i don't have
those
god i don't have pistol i'm missing
something
i'm missing something am i dumb
why won't you duck
oh i did something apparently i did
something enough
oh my knife is actually being useful for
now
[Music]
bang okay i did something
uh face oh okay can i get this please
mom go
bang boom guess bullets don't matter now
bang crystal
okay i wanted to pistol you're no lady
demetresku
and you never will be
[Music]
you're not dead are you are you dead
is that it no there's no way
that was barely a phase one oh
hi baby this is weird
hey what's up baby hey
what's up mold baby it's all right
it's all right man you must have been
through some [ __ ] that sweater has been
through some [ __ ] oh here i go
[Music]
ethan ethan
come on ethan come on ethan wake up
yeah i knew it chris ethan
he did it it's finished i think we've
finished each
other ethan
we gotta move oh
that's big
well hope my arm doesn't fall off
oh wow
oh boy
keep moving ethan you're going to kaboom
i'm in that thing that'll pull this
whole village sky high
hey look at me when i hit this trigger
we can't be anywhere near it
ah damn it me is waiting for you
she's alive you hear me alive
oh mia i'm so sorry
i love you keep ross safe hey
you tell yourself now come on it's not
that much further
watch over teach her to be strong
god
goodbye rosemary
rosemary ethan
[Music]
what's up
hello hello weird fungus baby
[Music]
gross
go go take us up now
wait where is ethan
get moving we have to get clear no we
can't go
not without my husband mia sit down and
strap in
not before you tell me where ethan is
i know he wouldn't abandon us
tell me what's going on where
what was that i told you to sit down
where is he
chris what have you done he's gone
i tried
he stayed so we could all escape
[Music]
i'm sorry
captain you need to see this
bsaa didn't send soldiers
this is a bio weapon what the hell were
they thinking
orders captain pick up the rest of the
squad
plot a course for bsa europe hq
someone's got to pay
that was good oh
i mean the story had its flaws of course
but oh
that's good i like it oh the village is
shadows
hard for the villager shadows
oh i i really like that that was very
fun i mean
there's always like a bit of campiness
to resident evil games and like the
horror genre kind of lends itself to
that but that was good that was a
fun game it was very fun very
just good stuff i don't know if the
story changed but i just assumed that
was the end credits
that rose do you think the little boy
will be able to touch the moon
nobody can touch the moon is too far
away wait what if he has a rocket ship
uh okay then you can touch it but it'd
be very very
cold
you were being silly i don't think
[Music]
hey dad happy birthday
sorry i missed last week i have a lot of
tests coming up
you know how it is
[Music]
talk of the goddamn devil
duty calls
i love you
yeah i found her where else
today of all days
we have a situation you're needed
evelyn don't you ever
call me that again oh oh it's just a
joke rose
funny joke i can show you things even
chris doesn't know i can do
we have a clear shot stand down
i can handle it she's just a kid
i want you to keep it together rose
you're a lot like him you know
i know
i know what they didn't show is the
grave next
lady didn't rescue was the full statue
the crystal was there
just was slightly out of frame but it
should have been there
anyway other than that so do a real
tearjerker is good
[Music]
you know you know
who's that guy walking who's walking
who was walking
the father's story is now done
it is done the onion rings
is done eight hours goddamn great dad
best at it oh
best dad
challenge oh look at all my show all
right uh
yeah save let's just put this at number
one again so that we have it up there
we did it gang we did it we did we
really did it
i'm very happy about that that was good
i like that you know we've been having
the remakes over the past two months and
you know resident evil 3
remix wasn't as good as 2 was but you
know it's really good to get back into
progressing the story of the game
and like seeing all the the cool stuff
that's there uh
extra content shop extra game the
mercenaries oh
hell yeah give me that [ __ ] i'm gonna
get the models
would have been good for those sweet
thumbnails wait where's my
bell i guess whatever but whatever
whatever whatever
family this is something you know lady d
would like that
you know i'm muted yeah you know
over for all the reforms oh god the baby
oh okay you know what i don't need to
see anything else okay here we go
ah
[Music]
wow
bella cassandra daniella whatever
[Music]
what are you looking at you
i can't rotate back oh yeah i bet they
did this on purpose because it's like
can't look up the skirt but that's my
design i'm just trying to get her to
look at me
look at me all right fine
get a good thumbnail here whoops
i guess i'm over all right the
mercenaries let's check out what this is
how
how what is this yeah we got time for
this
okay the murbah mary's
murbmeyer's village oh sure
i don't know what this is i have no idea
that's what i loved about resident evil
7 was all the game modes it was so fun
there's just so much to do first
purchase any equipment or weapons you
need from the shop and you will go out
into the field you would defeat as many
enemies possibly in the time limit get a
good rhythm going and build up combos
for extra barn
once you defeat your certain number amid
gold beard touch the golden fish and
move on
in that area you know i'll touch the
yellow or bone down get bark gun
beacon barbie dog blue all together
ability while three random bills
children
check out all the cool movies and match
fun style all these equipment name
i'll be in your favor all right thank
you
um other than that i guess
i need to talk to you just thinking of
ways to pass the time
that's great what did you say
i'm just gonna make more powerful more
comfortable one moment please
uh-huh is there really anything other to
do besides this
seems like the only thing to do all
right cool all right let's get out there
all sorts of weapons thank you for your
patron
you're welcome ooh okay cool
you got it door door
i'm ready to give this a go
where are you where are you give me
something whoa hey you're quick
oh hey that
[Applause]
blue orb i was told about the blue orb
the blue orbs are apparently cool
i'll do all brawn give that [ __ ] bang
boom
i'm so brawny
[Music]
all right give me that bang a boom
this is fun this is for funsies
this is for funsies oh golden orb
[Applause]
objective complete the goals appeared i
thought i needed
15. all right well i'll go then
okay do i have any other weapons do i
have any of them no i don't have any
other weapons
we talk about you crazy
okay
oh i get more per area okay
well i'm not they're giving me so much
how much do i really need
ah it's fine all finished okay let's do
it
start
oh hey what the hell
so you think you're tough huh huh
you think you're tough no okay
oh hi who where
who where someone somewhere who
hey oh hey
i was never even hit by an arrow in the
main game you think you can hit me
douchebag
music's cool though i don't even
remember this music being in the main
game
man what was i missing out when i was
playing give whatever this is
uh oh switching
oh yeah blade master oh give me the
blade
now i can actually see how much the
damage the blade actually did
i don't imagine it was very much but i'd
like to know
all right we're going nice
[Music]
where's everybody oh hey
no not god damn it you're not supposed
to be there you're supposed to be there
and you're not supposed to be there
you're supposed to be there who puts it
over there and who puts it over there
don't you dare do that to me
i'm coming for you [ __ ] oh you want
some of this oh yeah oh that's a lot of
damage
oh yeah that's a lot of damage oh that's
a lot of damage
me thinks i should have been upgrading
this a while ago
don't you dodge me yeah you better
[Music]
hello someone here
get poked [ __ ] oh [ __ ] not you oh god
wait hang on you're kind of tough
ow who's doing that
let me go go for that blue orb first
maybe it'll give me another melee
ability
since that's the important thing speed
we did i see another blue orb somewhere
am i crazy
i'm crazy prepare to get knifed
where'd you go what why
whoo
oh is oh hi hello i didn't know you were
there
that was my bad
and kaboom and give me your money and
i'm gonna go here and i'm gonna kill
nobody else you you're so
freaking far away
did i shoot that out of the air i am a
goddamn badass
can i please go thank you i'm amazing
i'm incredible i'm astonishing all right
you know that's enough of that
okay i know i could finish it but i will
save that for another time when i'm
playing on my own
this is ben resident evil village a
fantastic game
i thoroughly enjoyed this i really did i
think it was just super super fun
i think it was fantastic i like
obviously i was picking the story apart
a bit here and there but to be perfectly
honest
that was just fun and that's what this
game series has always been about it's
it's silly
it's really silly sometimes but the
ending did have heart
you know you could pick apart some of
the story points but the ending had
heart
you know the sacrifice of ethan you know
it didn't need to happen but you know
very rarely every dozen stories but it
was meaningful and then it looks like in
the next game you're going to play as
rose who was super powered
mold baby which should be pretty cool so
thank you everybody so much for watching
this i hope you enjoyed this series i
definitely did
i'm going to be moving on to more games
soon more scary games uh
i'm in canada for a couple more weeks
still so i've got
more canadian stuff on the way for you
to enjoy thank you everybody so much for
watching uh let me know what you thought
down the comments below leave a like go
back to the beginning watch resident
evil 7 2
3 all linked in the description and
suggested videos over there i've got
plenty more videos
and bob and wade and i have a new
podcast called distractible if you
haven't checked that out
definitely go give that a try it's just
us having fun making you laugh making
each other laugh and hopefully everyone
has a good time and there's a winner too
it's contest
so thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye